the new ipad pro is so good i didn't
just buy
one i bought two
what's going on guys my name is david
thomash and welcome back to the channel
that first statement is only a small
little lie
technically i did buy two ipad pros with
the m1 chip
however i didn't buy two for myself
obviously i only need one
the second was for my fiance the ipad
pro that you see behind me is a
phenomenal device
now as some of you may know on this
channel we talk about architecture and
technology
we've spoken about the old ipad
previously which i used to have
and i've passed that on now to upgrade
to this beast i've recommended the ipad
pro
as the number one ipad pick out of the
entire range for every architect
for a number of reasons on previous
videos today i want to break it down
into a very different method
i'm going to do your typical pros and
cons of the ipad from an architect's
point of view and i'm also going to
share with you the architectural uses
of an ipad pro especially with the new
m1 chip
this new m1 chip has actually
revolutionized how
quick and powerful the ipad is it's a
little bit mind-boggling
but it is phenomenal and it's something
that we definitely needed to step
towards
as we move towards a more mobile
universal
way of thinking and a more mobile
working from home situation with the
crazy world we live in today from the
get-go the
first thing i want to point out is that
the ipad pro can not
handle any architectural software not
because it isn't powerful enough but for
the simple fact
that archicad revit autocad whatever you
can name
doesn't actually have an app on the ipad
they all have their different apps on
the ipad which are more for just viewing
programs and viewing files but you can't
actually do anything
as an archicad user myself i would love
to see
archicad be able to run on the new ipad
pro
i think just that simple integration
with an m1 chip
an ipad pro and being able to have that
versatility and freedom anywhere
would make this the perfect device so
i purchased the ipad pro 11 inch i
didn't purchase the 12.9 inch for the
simple fact
that this is what i do most of the day
as an architect
i have either the ipad in my hand or
with this keyboard i have it
magically stuck on to the keyboard i
think as a product for architects the 11
inch ipad is a much better choice
personally speaking than the 12.9 inch
for the simple reason
it is the perfect size you can carry
this ipad
no issues whatsoever it's just under a
kilo i think don't quote me this isn't a
full tech review
this is an architect's interpretation of
what you need in an ipad
i think the weight the size makes it
completely versatile
i can sit this on my desk do whatever i
need i can take it to meetings carry it
to and from
but the best bit is and the absolute
best thing is about this whole ipad pro
besides the new m1 chip
is the simple ease and effectiveness of
taking it
off the keyboard now as you saw there
that demonstration
was so easy it was so seamless and it
was something that
just seems like should have been around
forever the simple fact that you can
just
click on your ipad you have a full
keyboard you can take it off
you have a tablet you have a drawing
board it's perfect
now i'll put the ipad on the side for
the minute and we'll talk about the
keyboard in itself
so the keyboard in itself is phenomenal
i had a little bit of doubt that the
keyboard would be any good
but the keyboard has a decent amount of
travel on the trackpad
it's backlit the trackpad is so smooth
feels just like a macbook does the only
con
of the keyboard is a simple fact it
doesn't bend
far enough so for example if i sit this
way
and i'm looking at it perfectly in line
it is perfect
however if you drop it lower and are
looking from a higher angle
the angle of the ipad just isn't there
so unfortunately the keyboard doesn't
bend far enough
back but overall it is an incredibly
well designed product
i do see it getting a little bit
scratched a little bit
worn pretty quickly so this is maybe
about a week old now if that
i probably don't have it for much longer
than a week and it's already starting to
show some scuff marks on the bottom
it will definitely get damaged as time
progresses
now as we take the ipad off the keyboard
and it becomes a regular ipad again
it does a phenomenal job the apple
pencil 2 which is an old edition
i'm not going to go into any detail
because well it
does exactly what it needs to do and
it's been doing it phenomenally for
years
so i don't think there's too much more
they can do with this pencil to make it
any better i'm sure they will but for
now it is a great utensil
and an accessory that is a must-have for
any architect
with an ipad this ipad once you pull it
off becomes the perfect drawing board in
my opinion
you can simply pull up a drawing start
marking up all over it
in a meeting with a client and just get
all the information down as quickly as
you need to now with incorporation of
the new m1 chip it is actually a beast
of a product
to put this into perspective this 4k
rendering machine behind me
cost about three and a half thousand
dollars just for the tower
my imac pro at work does a decent job
but this still beats it hands down there
is
one pdf in particular from one job in
particular
that has so many hatches and
so many different layers on it that
every single computer
ever try to open it up on struggles
every time i used to open up on my old
ipad the ipad crashed
every time i opened up on last
generation's
12.9 inch ipad pro that ipad crashed
i opened that document up on this ipad
when i first got it
it was part of my meeting i wasn't even
thinking about it it took a few seconds
for me to realize
that there was no glitching every single
hatch was loaded
instantly and i didn't even notice that
i was opening one of the most complex
pdf files
that no computer i've used to date could
handle
i know that seems like a very silly
comparison it's a pdf you should be fine
it should open
but some of the pdfs become so complex
with so many layers so many hatches
i'm sure you guys have experienced that
that computer struggled to load it and
you just have to sit there and wait for
it to load one hatch
load another hatch or load another layer
the last pro i'll go into
is the simple fact that we'll click that
back on there
it lasts forever now i'm not kidding
when i say this
the ipad pro with the new m1 chip has
some serious engineering behind it i'll
wake up it'll be fully charged 100
ready to go for my day my day starts at
5 30 in the morning but i don't start
using my ipad until about 7
7 30 in the morning i won't stop using
my ipad until about 9pm at night at the
earliest now i've done this for a week
straight just to make sure it wasn't a
fluke but it didn't last
and it's gonna die on me every other day
every single day
using it from 7 30 in the morning
probably having it open
at work for the eight hour work day for
five hours straight
just lit up typing on it using it like
normal
and then typing emails and responding to
everybody and running my businesses at
night time
that ipad battery only fell down to
about
15 to 17 every single night
now that is phenomenal i can't use my
laptop
for more than eight hours without it
dying however the m1 chip has been able
to revolutionize how it manages
its battery and its performance so it
doesn't chew up as much power as you
would think
overall the battery life has been great
the performance
is exceptional now it is in all sunshine
and rainbows with this ipad
unfortunately there are a few cons
the first is just basic for example the
camera is positioned exactly where your
hand goes for the power button
so if i bring this ipad back and just
simply showcase
that the power button is up here and the
camera is
just there every time i go to unlock it
it'll tell me
that the camera is covered and i can't
deck my face so
every time i go to open it my hands over
the ipad perfectly placed
it's just giving me that silly little
arrow and saying nope
your face can't be detected and you're
going to have to type in your pin
so the positioning of the camera on the
ipad isn't really an m1 thing it isn't
really an architect thing it's just
annoying to be honest now as an
architect who uses archicad
24 7 i'm so ingrained to just
tapping that escape key and trying to
get out of whatever i'm using
unfortunately the ipad pro keyboard does
not
have an escape key it's not a con to
the ipad itself it's just a design flaw
that i think as architects and
architectural students
we're going to be in that constant habit
of tapping the wrong button
the keyboard in itself is also very
difficult to open you need two hands to
be able to open this thing properly
because it's just
so heavy at the start once you crank it
open a little bit
it's perfectly fine but it's just that
little bit too heavy
as you can tell my cons aren't really to
do with the physical ipad itself
or with anything to do with architecture
because so far
i've found no errors in the ipad pro
that have let me to come up with some
sort of negative response to tell you
guys
that no don't buy this ipad because it's
no good
literally the only thing it can't do is
it can't run archicad
it can't run revit but maybe we'll get
there one day i don't know
i truly am hoping we will get there one
day now from an architectural point of
view and from an architect's point of
view
the reason i purchased an ipad pro was
for the simple fact that it is
a workhorse for anything that you have
to do in an office environment
it is phenomenal so even if you're not
an architecture student or if you're not
an architect
no matter what profession you're in i
think an ipad is becoming one of those
staple accessories
in the professional industry as an
architect though there is a minimum
bundle that i would recommend
you can simply buy the ipad pro with the
pencil combination
or you can go to the full bundle like i
bought with the ipad pro the pencil and
the keyboard
having that freedom and luxury of all
three really makes it the perfect tool
as an architect so i'll give you an
example
if i'm sitting in a meeting with a
client it's quite often that i'm typing
the minutes of the meeting
but i'm also having that ipad open
needing to draw
all over the plans so i can mark it up
and then change those comments on
archicad later now in a typical
environment without an ipad
you'd have a full set of a1 plans
marking up all over them a sketch pad
and paper writing down minutes and it
just takes forever
now i can actually have this ipad on the
stand open up with a keyboard typing my
minutes on the side with the pencil
scribbling all over the drawings as we
talk through the project now i think
this is
extremely useful because it saves time
this is one of the factors that if
you're an architect i'm sure you can all
relate
time is very valuable because we never
have enough time in the day to complete
everything we need to do
so simply saving ourselves an hour two
or three
is incredible and worth the money for me
i can now type my minutes of the meeting
in the meeting mark up all the
documentation
in the meeting and flick them off to
either myself
a drafts person the client whoever needs
that information
as soon as that meeting is over so i no
longer have to go back to my desk
type up all those minutes try and
remember what it was about
and then mark up all the scan it through
take a photo of it or do whatever i
needed to do to get it onto a digital
version to be able to send away
here and now with the ipad pro it's
powerful enough that i can have
documentation open i can have
a pdf document open i can have
everything open in the background
quickly flicking through
and marking up all over the drawings at
the same time
i think the last meeting i tested this
in i saved myself
two hours now i've done it previously in
the past so i know that i've saved
myself two hours
it was a very long meeting i was typing
the minutes i was marking the drawings
up
and liaising with the clients about
every single change now usually
i'd have to go back and do all that work
again now i simply save myself two hours
which is incredible it means i could get
on with the next project
i could keep designing and i could keep
creating so as an administrative tool
it is incredible just on a side note if
anybody tells you that australia is
always hot it is not it is freezing cold
today
so seriously thank you to cuts for
sending over a bunch of hoodies for me
to just get me through this winter
because it is cold in australia it is
not hot all the time and whoever says is
100 lying to you
if you want to grab one of these cuts
jumpers or anything else from cuts
you'll notice that i've been wearing a
black shirt in every single one of my
videos for years
that's because i've been working with
cuts for such a long time and i truly
believe in the product
i get nothing out of this so if you want
to go down below
hit the link for the cuts shirts you can
grab yourself a shirt that lasts
years i literally have about 40 of them
in my cupboard
and every single one has held up for so
long
i know they're a little bit pricey but
again they're just worth it in my
personal opinion and when you're down
there there is a number of other links
for architects architecture students
and everybody in the industry if there's
something that you need or if you need
assistance with anything there's a
discord link down below
that you can chat to me at any point in
time and i'll help you out as much as i
can
the community on discord is also growing
we're slowly building a little
architectural community on there
that is able to help each other out
there's been a couple questions asked
from different people all over the world
and it's just incredible to see this
community growing and this community
coming together
it makes me looking at a camera and
talking to a camera feel a little bit
more real
otherwise it just feels like i'm a
little bit crazy talking to a camera in
a room all by myself
so i'd appreciate it if you check out
the links down below hit the subscribe
button if you want to continue seeing
these videos
and also hit the like button to help
with the youtube algorithm there's only
three apps i really use on this ipad
from an architectural point of view
that i can't fault morfolio trace is
number one
i'm not sponsored in any way shape
performed by them i've done a little bit
of work
just promoting them before because i
really genuinely like the app
but nothing from the company so morfolio
trace is incredible
adobe photoshop is becoming more and
more handy on the ipad just to simply
fix up bits and pieces that aren't
correct
and finally apple notes it is the
simplest app of all time
but it's just so easy to draw and markup
on and sketch up a detail to send to
somebody who needs to
or if you're in a meeting with a client
and they're asking you how does this
work
in real life you can sketch up that
detail in
seconds and it just makes that
experience of using the ipad
as an architect and using the skills
that you've developed over a lifetime
so much easier to convey than they ever
have before
now the simplest reason i recommend the
ipad pro
over every other ipad is the screen
i didn't buy the 12.9 even though the
screen is phenomenally better
but i think the screen on the 11 inch is
so good
that there's not much better that you
can get if you compare them side by side
yes you'll see the difference
yes you'll know that the 12.9 is a
better resolution display
but with the 11 inch you're never going
to know that
the screen is so good that it doesn't
matter anymore
it doesn't matter how good the screen
gets beyond this that 11 inch ipad pro
at 120 hertz with full refresh rate
and just how crystal clear it is
can't be beaten now what's my overall
verdict i guess if you're an architect
or if you're an architecture student
it's yes and no
if you're an architecture student i
wouldn't recommend the ipad pro
or any other ipad for the simple fact it
can't run any architectural software
so you're definitely going to need to
run autocad
archicad revit potentially rendering
softwares
like enscape twin motion you could go up
to unreal
engine you could go all the way through
to the high-end rendering packages
that an ipad can more than likely handle
but just isn't there from a software
point of view if this changes in the
near future with ipad os 15
and they introduce something that allows
you to run it like a laptop where you
can
actually run architectural software
throw that opinion out the window
go buy one today because as a product it
is phenomenal for all architecture
students
i think it is perfect for anybody at
university if it could do that
until then i'd still recommend a good
laptop over an ipad and then of course
a desktop over everything else because
as an architecture student
you just go through an abundance of
different programs trying to get
all that information down on paper
trying to get a good grade as an
architect on the other hand
i think it's a fine line architects
obviously have a variety of different
roles and an architect can be
a completely different role in itself
you could be an architect that literally
just sits at a computer and designs
all day long or you could be an
architect that liaises with clients
sits at the computer does administrative
roles runs their own business
has more of a senior management role if
you have that senior management role
where
you are required to do some
administrative things some client
liaising
and anything in between there yes hands
down
ipad pro with the new m1 chip is
miles better than anything we've ever
had before
and probably will be for a couple
seasons now until they come up with an
m5 or something like that
where it supersedes this incredibly for
everybody else that might be watching
this video it doesn't matter what
position you're in or what industry
you're in
if you're in some sort of leadership
role or if you're just a student
that doesn't require any architectural
programs that's just going to run word
excel things like that i think the ipad
has just
surpassed the laptop anyway that's all
for me today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below make sure
you also hit that like button to help
with the youtube algorithm
and as always i'll see you next monday